that is the single understanding exact
that we share our being when everyone
and everything must be the foundation of
any truly civilized culture it must be
at the origin of a civilized culture if
we want some measure of the indication
of some measure of our establishment in
our true nature I'm not sure that
looking at an brain scan is the place to
look we should look to the extent to
which we are at peace and happy for no
reason that would be a better test
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
ooh imperturbable peace and causeless
joy its ultimate purpose I would suggest
is that it be is for the reality to
shine unobscured through the illusion so
the the illusion being the appearance of
multiplicity and diversity which for
most of us conceals its reality I would
suggest that the purpose we can speak of
purpose is for the the the illusion the
appearance of multiplicity and diversity
not to conceal its reality but to reveal
its reality to express it to communicate
it to share it to celebrate it in other
words for for the appearance to become
increasingly transparent to its reality
someone's opinion me contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality hey everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sockin I am super excited and grateful
to be featuring Rupert Spira on the show
hi Rupert hi Anna thank you so much for
joining us
I have been a big fan of what you've
been communicating and for those that
don't know I'd love to read you Rupert's
bio Rupert Spira is a leading non dual
teacher of the direct path a synthesis
of many global wisdom traditions his
eloquent use of metaphor points people
with great efficacy to self-realization
he has authored several books his
YouTube channel is receiving millions of
views he's hosting retreats across the
US and Europe and he's a notable studio
potter with work in public and private
collections I'm going to synthesize some
of Rupert's key teaching and then we'll
start after that over thousands of years
we've been experienced uh deaiing
consciousness and metaphysics only
recently since the scientific revolution
has a global paradigm of materialism
become dominant industrialization has
connected billions of people to
electricity and the internet plus much
more the revelation of quantum mechanics
blew our minds and now the 21st century
is knocking how can science possibly
probe the most primal question of our
existence what is consciousness if
you'll join me for a moment in a game
I'd like to ask you to close your eyes
and imagine you are in bed dozing off
you immediately begin dreaming that
you're in a kitchen pouring yourself
some tea your adoring the high quality
of this full
immersion where you can literally even
smell the aroma you accidentally spill a
little and suddenly you snap back to
laying in your bed with your eyes open
what you just experienced we predict is
a microcosm reflecting the macrocosm in
other words the same way we dream a
reality and take a first-person
perspective is precisely what we are
doing with this reality it's recursive
reality calls on us to dream for one
third of our lives quite an obvious hint
one indivisible infinite consciousness
in a dream fully immersed in the high
quality completely forgetting it is a
dream why we see people running around
seeking objects relationship substances
anything is because they want to /
pierce the veil of separation to feel
whole the irony is you already are what
you seek Rupert how was that I can't add
much to that okay actually if if you
know if that's if that's the case then
that makes me happy I'm always happy but
that makes me especially happy because
it's very important to me
to take what these diverse leaders like
yourself around the world are
communicating and be able to try and
compress the messages into the most
relatable stories which is basically
what you do with your metaphors
and yes you've said infinite
consciousness is the ultimate dreamer
whose activity is the universe yes I
really like that as well I want to UM I
want to visualize your your lineage
quickly so let's go to your teacher is
Francis Lucille correct and you did you
meet him around 1995 ish or when 1997 97
okay and then for 13 years you studied
with him so up until about 2010 or so
yes
we just come back a little bit further
yes and to my late teens where I first
became interested in these matters and
so I started attending a school or a
society in in London called the study
society and it was essentially a school
of classical Advaita Vedanta so for
twenty years or so I was in this
classical inviter
teaching practicing mantra meditation
and exploring the classical non dual
teachings and it was after 20 years of
that that I then met Francis yes he
introduced me to the the direct approach
and he also introduced me to the tantric
approach which he had learned through
his teacher Jean Klein yes and as you
then spent 13 years or so with Francis
before I started yes speaking about
these matters myself yes yes very few
people have the opportunity to be
introduced to non duality at the age of
16 which is what you had that's true I
was fortunate my mother and stepfather
at the time were both very interested in
these matters they originally went to
college house that the study society in
London and so they introduced me to call
it house the adviser teaching they also
practiced them they've levy turning so I
was introduced I was very fortunate at
an early age during my mid to late teens
to come across this understanding to
meet a lot of people and spend really
most of my time with a with a lot of
people most of them older than me at
that time who were interested in these
matters so this really from a mid teens
up until my mid-thirties the this the
classical er advisor or non-dual
approach was really the the backdrop to
my life and was really the main focus of
my life during those years
and in Francis's lineage goes to Jean
Klein who he met in 1975 and then and
then and then Jean Klein was with
Panditji Rao in 1950 and punditji was a
professor of Sanskrit in Bangalore and
Lin he came from a Linde lineage of
advaita teachers
yes that's true Zhang was also a yoga
teacher so what was unusual about you
John Klein and I think immensely
valuable is is that he his approach
incorporated the body and didn't reject
the body and and indeed the world as
some of the classical I divided the
teachings coming out of India did so
this was the this is what I referred to
earlier as the tantric approach which is
an approach of inclusion you're
including the totality of the experience
rather than the masculine vitae approach
where the the body and the world are
considered at least in some expressions
of a dark are considered dangerous
realms where we might lose ourselves so
on so that was something very valuable
immensely valuable the Francis
introduced me to this this inclusive
path yes as I posed to the path of
exclusion or the path of discrimination
which which don't get me wrong I had the
highest regard for and spent 20 years on
that path myself and it was immensely
valuable but there was something
incomplete about it for me because of
this lack of inclusion of the body and
the world and of course during these
early years I was practicing as you said
earlier as a Potter I was spending my my
days making pots in my studio my and my
nights reading ramana maharshi as a
potter i-i-i loved things i spent my
life making things I loved things I love
beauty and so there was no question of
renouncing yes okay so also it wasn't
until I met Francis that this that that
my love of beauty that I was exploring
in my studio by day and my love of truth
that I was exploring at home by night
really came together and I realized that
really the love of beauty in the love of
truth are indeed the same thing yes yes
and this is this is key and we're going
to touch on this throughout our
conversation is this full embrace of the
beauty of what is what we have here and
the full unleashing of of inner
potential artistry gifts into our into
our reality I want to I want to relate
what you just said also to Sri Aurobindo
quickly and the mother mere al fossa and
integral yoga in the sense that they
also highly highly emphasized the
importance of anchoring the divine
anchoring the full embodiment in every
day and that way it basically butterfly
effects out into everything that we do
with our family our friends our work our
relationships everything and that's the
the process of the the beginnings of a
more beautiful and truthful and underway
into the true nature of reality world
yes now Rupert ultimately the biggest
questions lie in the field of
metaphysics the what is the ultimate
nature of reality why is there something
rather than nothing what is the nature
of consciousness and then kind of
science and spirituality basically do
their best to understand that that's
ultimate
what we're here doing is trying to
understand that and a good way to you've
you've said this question before a good
way to begin your Atma vichara self
inquiry is by asking a question what is
my source where do I come from what is
the what is the genesis of all of this
what is my real nature and you had a
really good conversation with Sam Harris
as well because I think it was a good
way to juxtapose the consciousness only
with someone that is also interested in
spirituality but also has a grounding in
deep science and materialism and so he
kind of said in return that there's a
big temptation to make consciousness the
very first principle and that he then
said that that would mean that
consciousness then subsumes cosmogony
the Big Bang and the reasons for that
but then you counter with the question
what is it that knows or is aware of
your experience yeah well I think
there's there's good reason for making
consciousness the first principle simply
because it is the first principle of our
experience so why not start there it's
just an undeniable fact of experience
that consciousness or that all that is
or could ever be known is experience and
consciousness is the fundamental and
primary we prerequisite of all
experience so if we want to build a
model of reality why not start there it
is the primary element of our experience
so it isn't that scientific just to
start with something that is actually
experienced something that is real in
experience rather than starting with an
abstract idea namely the existence of
something called
matter outside and independent of
consciousness which nobody has ever
found or could ever find or will ever
find because all it is ever possible to
find it's the content of consciousness
that to me is abstract what what to me
is really realistic and scientific is to
investigate experience what it asked us
of what is the primary element of
experience it is obviously consciousness
and to build our model of reality based
on that rather than on something that is
abstract okay so the take is that the
most the ground or the most fundamental
first principle is experience and then
that is consciousness that is awareness
and then that is the nature of reality
is that is consciousness is awareness
and not that there is a big bang that
happens 13.8 billion years ago and after
the billions of years of evolution of
matter then the complexity of body
activity creates a consciousness that is
is there is there a point of any
synthesis there or model of sorry sorry
- yeah
that that model of reality is based on
the evidence of thought and perception
it presumes that what we perceive of the
outside world is in Israel in the way
that it is presented to our senses and
that thoughts interpretation of sense
perception is correct and extrapolated
from this model of reality we go all the
way back to the Big Bang but this is
this idea is based on the presumption
that a set
and it's interpretation through thought
is correct okay okay it might not be
maybe our census done yeah maybe the
combination of perception and conception
that is the finite mind maybe they don't
give us an accurate model of reality
maybe reality is filtered through sense
perception and appears in accordance
with its limitations in other words the
limitations that we see that we believe
pertain to reality may simply be the
limitations of the perceiving apparatus
the finite mind through which we
perceive we cannot be sure that the
limitations that belong to our
perceiving apparatus yes actually
pertain to reality itself how do we know
that we are not simply seeing an
objective ization or a reification
of the limitations of our own mind yes
yes after all when the activities of
thought and perceptions subside as they
do in deep sleep time and space also
subside when thought and perception
begins again when thought begins again
time seems to begin when perception
begins again space seems to begin and
this happens every every single time
thought and perception disappear
objective experience disappears every
time it arises again objective
experience arises again is that a
coincidence could there be a connection
I would suggest that there is and these
are those hints that we were mentioning
earlier these most simple hints in
science there's Occam's razor the most
simplest is likely the correct and in
this case it's so in a sense simple and
it is so it's so much like a hint
absolutely I liked your analogy
your summary at the beginning about the
dream we're given numerous hints as to
the nature of reality and if as you say
we use Occam's razor
Rock'em said that of two competing
theories we should always choose the one
that makes the least assumptions so here
we have two models of reality one that
or reality appears within consciousness
and is the activity of consciousness
that doesn't make an assumption it is
actually our experience the second
assumption is that what we what we know
of reality is generated by something
outside consciousness namely matter and
indeed gives rise to consciousness in
other words they the second theory
suggests that that which is never
experienced namely matter independent of
consciousness gives rise to that which
is alone experienced namely
consciousness so this this makes an
enormous assumption the assumption of
the existence of something outside
consciousness well if it was necessary
to appeal to the existence of something
called matter in order to explain our
experience then it would be legitimate
under Occam's razor to refer to such a
substance but it is quite possible to
make sense of our entire experience of
reality referring only to consciousness
in the way that you suggested with the
dream analogy and it this consciousness
only model also not only enables us to
make sense of our experience of reality
but it enables us to make sense of many
phenomena that the matter model does not
is not able to explain so the
consciousness only model has a far
greater explanatory power
the matter model if we were to visualize
the Ouroboros the snake's head eating
its tail if we were to envision the
wholeness of that then is then the the
infinite consciousness is then present
at the oh it's present everywhere but
it's present at the Godhead and the tail
in the sense that the tail portion this
model of science that currently is that
many of us agree to an consensus enjoy
the benefits of is at the detail point
infinite consciousness is at the tail
point and the Big Bang is the process of
the tail point itself still evolving
over time into what we have so there is
still that process and it's going
towards a Tilos of a Godhead of the
continuation is that approximately how
do you resonate with that I think then
the model of them of the Big Bang is own
a model that is accurate
reasonably accurate within the
parameters of sense perception and
thought it is an interpretation of
reality within the limits of perception
and conception and is as such a
reasonable interpretation and has is a
useful interpretation I'm not suggesting
that I love science I have numerous
scientist friends I have great respect
for what they do it's a valid
interpretation and complete your car
literally made us what we are really yes
so it's a it's a valid relative model of
reality that that is useful has numerous
useful applications but it is not an
accurate model of reality and that there
are no accurate models of reality even
that the consciousness only model that I
am suggesting it is full show that there
are no accurate knowledge interesting
and that's the idea of the elusiveness
of the mystery and the beauty of that
and to continued openly and blissfully
in complete honor of that mystery while
while simultaneously being interested in
the models in making and playing with
models that can help us live better
lives yes ok ok let's let's let's go
into identity this is very important
because in in Sanskrit the word Ankara
is very interesting the ego or egoism
and so the ideas that do you identify
with the ego do you identify with the
the limited finite self in this body and
nothing else or do you identify your
self as universal as transcendent and
there's a huge difference between those
and also we can call something like an
awakening awakenings or enlightenment or
this the process whether it be gradually
or suddenly to feeling Universal or and
transcendent the process that we all are
aiming to pierce that veil and science
does I would like to hear your take on
the science does a very interesting job
at revealing the unity and the
interconnectedness and I and I would
love to see more spiritualists embody
some of these scientific understandings
of unity because I think that would help
with the synth
but also scientists themselves like in
1945 if they were more spiritually awake
they wouldn't have dropped bombs on
Hiroshima Nagasaki so there's that other
side as well scientists can also gain a
decent amount of spiritual knowledge the
general idea is this
you cannot inside spoon this you cannot
you take 20,000 breaths of air every
single day you can't live without oxygen
but you can't take one of those 20,000
breaths without summoning the
photosynthesis that is happening from
phytoplankton and trees around the
planet so you are deeply interconnected
with the oxygen cycle of the planet with
photosynthesis and so a question is
something to ask oneself is do i what
where where do I draw a line or like a
boundary when when do I say that I am
NOT the phytoplankton and the trees that
provide with oxygen all of these the
approximation is twenty-five sextillion
which is ten with 21 zeros after it
oxygen molecules that I am
inhaling every breath every breath and
then those are oxygenating my body where
do I draw the line I have I have a
thousand we we all each have a thousand
species of bacteria in our gut
microbiome so do you affiliate yourself
with the one thousand species of gut
bacteria and how they have two million
total genes versus you have twenty
thousand genes so a hundred times more
genetic expression happening from those
from those gut microbial another example
is when do you when do you take if you
take the Apple or the banana and when
you when do you become when does the
apple or banana become you when you when
you bite it and you begin chewing it
when it actually becomes digested and
you go through the process of cellular
respiration and the adenosine
triphosphate powers you and energizes
you so this is these are the things that
science literally
proves interconnectedness and unity and
I'm curious what do you think about the
scientific angle and how it can help the
spiritual angle of non-duality flourish
so you you've just demonstrated from a
physical point of view the that we as
individual people or we as a as a as a
body are intimately connected with the
universe in fact not even not even
intimately connected we aren't even
apart from the universe as a
independently existing entity either to
be connected with it or or not connected
with it there is no clear distinction
even from a physical point of view which
is the point of view you've just
demonstrated and which as you say quite
rightly science makes very clear it is
an arbitrary line but the the non-dual
understanding goes much further than
this it doesn't presume to begin with
that what we essentially are is a body
whether or not we are intimately
connected to the universe the non-dual
understanding first and the non-dual
approach makes this deep investigation
into what we essentially are not most of
us most people believe and feel that
what they essentially are is is a body
which has generated consciousness inside
it in particular inside the brain and
that the body as such sorry that
consciousness as such is born or appears
when the body appears that it evolves as
the body involves and that it dies or
disappear disappears when there when the
body disappears in other words the
consciousness shares the limits and the
destiny of the body this is the standard
approach
in in our culture and even from this
approach what you have just demonstrated
the interconnectedness of of us this
apparent body this body is absolutely
true
then on your approach as I said goes
musty but it first of all investigates
what we essentially are and it trained
in this investigation we trace back our
experience of ourselves discarding
everything that is not essential to us
our thoughts are obviously not essential
to us they are always appearing and
disappearing our feelings likewise
sensations perceptions activities
relationships these are all elements of
experience that are added to us they
remain for a while and then they leave
us but what is the us what is the
essential irreducible element of our
self and if we if we undergo this
experiment and it's a very simple
experiment anybody can do it we end up
with just a simple being our simple
self-aware being it's like it's like
undressing at night when we when we go
to bed at night we we take off all the
layers of clothes each layer is of
course superfluous to us that clothes
are changing all the time and we get to
our naked bodies that that element of
our self relatively speaking that cannot
be removed that is our naked being well
if we do the same thing relative to our
experience and we take off so to speak
our thoughts feelings memories
sensations perceptions activities and
relationships we end up with pure
awareness and this is a pure self-aware
being so this is the first great
discovery and that's what we share is
that yeah I was just going to say that
the first step is the discovery I am
awareness this is not yet what is
referred to as enlightenment or
awakening in the traditions then the
next step is to investigate the nature
of it's a review so
we took off all of the layers of
identity and then we got to the most
primal the most first rinse appalled
which was though awareness yes we took
off everything that we were identified
with everything that we thought was
essential to us thoughts feelings etc
and we got back to our own naked
identity our original our original face
as they say in the Zen tradition the
essential nature of the mind as they say
in in but isn't the self as they say in
there in the Hindu tradition so that's
the first discovery I am what I
essentially am is simply the fact of
being aware or awareness itself the next
discovery is is to discover the nature
of the awareness that I am that the
discovery that it is ever-present that
it has no limits and that its nature is
it is inherently peaceful and
unconditionally fulfilled and that this
is the ranking that is traditionally
referred to is enlightenment so I would
say this was that the second recognition
happiness is my nature yes the third
great recognition the meditation is not
something that we do it's what we are we
are the happiness the bliss the yes the
essential nature of the awareness that I
am is peace or happiness and then the
third we can come back and just yes the
third great recognition which you hinted
at the the recognition that the being
that we essentially are is shared by not
only everyone but everything in other
words everyone and everything derive
their apparently independent existence
from a single infinite and indivisible
reality or whole whose nature is well
ultimately
it is unnameable because all names have
evolved to describe the content of
experience but if we are going to speak
about these matters let's give it a
provisional name in these circles we
tend to speak of it as consciousness or
awareness in religious circles it is
referred to as God's presence or Brahman
but in common parlance it is referred to
as I myself my being the the one
infinite and indivisible reality which
doesn't connect us all because in the
ultimate analysis there is no all there
there is not a multiplicity and
diversity of objects themselves each
with their own independent existence to
be connected in the ultimate analysis
there are no independently existing
objects or self there is simply a single
infinite indivisible whole which is
refracted through the prism of the
finite mind and appears as many things
and many people so as a concession to
the belief that there are many things
and many people we can say that we all
share our reality but in the earth if we
will really want to be try to be more
accurate in the ultimate reality that
there is no we there are no separate
objects ourselves either to be United or
not be united there is simply the unity
of being that appears as this
multiplicity and diversity and and the
recognition where we are speaking of
this in in intellectual terms and
analyzing it with the use of our
rational mind
but the recognition that we share our
being is a familiar recognition that
millions of people I would suggest that
everybody has some taste of and that is
the experience of love love is the
recognition that we share our being yeah
yeah yeah there's several things there
there is the you mentioned the the DAO
that can be
named is not the eternal Dow there's
also a hot dog whoa dude which is that
the unity of all being the unity of all
existence so this is it's also
interesting it's such a perennial wisdom
it's literally across all of these
ancient spiritual traditions across the
planet of course it is because it's
what's true because it's fun what's real
at anyone at any time irrespective of
their location on the earth at the time
in which they have been built anyone
that goes to the nature of reality by
definition goes to the same reality
because reality is always the same theme
which is not a thing so of course all
these diverse expressions of truth or
reality are going to point to the in
their own unique ways a going to point
ultimately to the same reality because
reality is always real it is always the
same it doesn't reality is not one thing
in India and another thing in America
it's not one thing in two thousand years
ago and another thing today reality is
and in two thousand years time reality
will be exactly what it is now although
if if human beings still exist then they
will express it in very very different
ways the language we're speaking will
seem so arcade to through and even we
cannot imagine what that language will
be yeah yeah and we in in the way that
science also aims to approach this and
validate this is through this unbroken
chain of evolution to that source point
and even the way of perceiving it that
way and all of these other ways in terms
of trying to pierce the veil of where is
this boundary and at least the slow
process of getting beyond the veil of
the ego to the universal to the
transcendent to the unity of all
existence is there's so many of these
different ways up this mountain to that
nature of reality but like you say at
that pinnacle point at that nature of
reality the ultimate point is
that infinite consciousness and I I
think this is a very interesting way to
put it is there is this ultimate point
so this kind of leads me into the next
point which is I would love to talk to
you about this analogy of the symphony
and the reason why I'd like to talk to
you about this analogy is because the
unity of all being is the symphony
infinite consciousness is the symphony
it is the the the the this the seemingly
or the illusory which is that it does
it's the way that it appears is is as it
can can lead people off from the from
the truth so it's not as it appears that
the symphony has a good analogy in the
sense that and I want to hear what you
think about this there's the unity of
all being
but then there's there is this again
this illusory this the this the self
this Alan and Rupert and all of these
eight billion seemingly individuals but
part of the beauty of the symphony
analogy is that people don't reside in
the ultimate which is okay non-duality
excellent and rather it's both you the
unity it's non-duality excellent and
it's also I get the opportunity to be on
we get to be artists right we get to we
get to make great studio pottery right
we get to make great content we get to
engineer we get to design we get to
tinker but we do that all from the place
of unity we do that all from the place
of non-duality is that about right how
does that resonate yes ultimately
everything absolutely everything comes
from or is an expression or modulation
of consciousness or awareness I use the
words synonymously now some of our
thoughts and feelings and our subsequent
activities and relationships are
mediated through the belief I am a
temporary finite separate self so even
though those thoughts and feelings and
the activities and relationships that
they generate ultimately come from
consciousness they do not express the
what is true of the nature of
consciousness or reality why because
they are filtered through the belief in
separation and therefore Express that
belief ultimately of course they still
come from the same place that everything
comes from so I would suggest that true
creativity as any could could be said to
be any form be that forming in words and
music in any art is a form that comes
unmediated directly from our deepest
reality or being that is not filtered
through the sense of separation although
it requires the agency of the person to
articulate that expression the the
source of that expression doesn't come
from a person that the feeling of being
temporary I know it is an expression of
the reality that lies behind so to speak
the the finite mind or the separate
person and which is why the artist calls
themselves a channel so often yes yes
and and and the purpose of this art that
that is informed by the background of
the lens is to bring the truth or the
reality
that is inherent in it out into the
world in order to be shared with
humanity yes yes and in that this is the
idea that I may be a violinist but you
may be a saxophone player and there is
also a drummer and there's a cellist and
there's the clarinet and that's the idea
of and they're all and by the way two
clarinets are maybe playing different
harmonies and so there's that as well so
that's the idea that all eight billion
are in that sense our artists in the
symphony and that they have their you
they have a unique expression yes okay
go ahead
yeah can I upgrade your metaphor please
upgrade it yes because your metaphor is
is is it's a beautiful metaphor and and
it's true I can see what what you're
trying to articulate but the the first
metaphor that you referred to the
metaphor of the dream has I think is
more efficient and is clearer so okay
can i if you want you can go back to the
the symphony but can I really articulate
what you're saying in terms of the of
the dream metaphor because I think it's
much easier to speak about and much
easier to understand so as you said in
your introduction take what happens to
us when we have a dream at night we
where are you where are you located now
and where do you live in South Dakota
right now you're into code okay so say
say and you fall asleep in South Dakota
and you imagine that you're walking on
the streets of London
you don't view the the dreamed streets
of London directly from your mind asleep
in South Dakota your mind has forgotten
that it is dreaming it has overlooked
itself and your own mind has located
itself within its own dream you now seem
to be Alan
walking on the streets of London that is
the only way your mind can perceive the
dream by overlooking itself locating
itself in the dream and viewing what is
in fact its own activity from this
localized perspective in the dream as
the streets of London now everybody else
that you encounter on the streets of
London which from your limited
perspective seem who seemed to be
separate people are in fact the activity
of your own indivisible mind when you
wake up in the morning you realize the
entire dream all the different people
and all the different objects were the
activity there were no entities there it
was all the activity of my own mind it
only appeared as a multiplicity and
diversity of objects themselves from the
illusory perspective of the self that I
seemed to become in the dream now let's
say that you now you meet one of these
people you meet an old friend on the
streets of London in your dream you
haven't seen his friend for a long time
you both go to a cafe you sit down and
you have a conversation about something
and you both disagree what you're
talking about American politics ok and
you completely disagree with your friend
about so you you you you have one point
of view your friend has another
completely point of view so your point
of view you you each have a series of
thoughts you think that your thoughts
are right you think your friends
thoughts are incorrect but but so you
can have two completely different
thoughts opposing thoughts that seem to
be completely opposite to each other and
are indeed in the dream opposite to each
other when you wake up you realize that
both the true thoughts and the untrue
thoughts were generated in your own mind
and that goes for the the present
sensations the unpleasant sensations
the kind thoughts the unkind thoughts
the loving feelings the unloving
feelings the behavior that is
intelligent and loving the behavior that
is cruel and unjust it all ultimately is
the activity of a single universal mind
yes yes in so in the analogy the idea
then is that infinite consciousness has
within in the symphony has take we we we
are we the all the artists in all the
seemingly individual artists have the
the we we have a filter the filter of
the the mind in the dream that then is
we that there's there's a process of
realizing for the the the fight the
seemingly finite minds to realize that
ah AHA the infinite consciousness and
and and it's both a ha the infinite
consciousness and it is also that it's
not a ha ok and but it's but it's aha
and so it's the realization and it's the
creation from that place of realization
so then the Claire the clarinet player
the violinist
etc they create their melody harmony
from that place of AHA and yet exactly
exactly
let's keep both metaphors alive so let's
let's take there are essentially two
possibilities let's go back I'm going to
translate what you've now said into the
dream metaphor you're back on this by
the way Rupert I just want to say I
think this is so powerful for the
synthesis of east and west because
though the East is very on the non-dual
and the West is very on the individual
and which is very interesting because
then it can see
to size them into that so let's go back
to the and the dream analogy you meet
your friend so you you you other dreamed
carried for that let's continue to call
you Alan and your friend he's calls
let's say he's called David so Alan and
David are talking in the cafe so let's
say that that Alan has recognized that
the the essential nature of his mind the
essential nature of himself is shared
with everyone and everything although he
Allen still perceives from the localized
perspective of his body he can only see
the streets of London from where he's
sitting on his cafe table but he knows
that the nature of that which perceives
in him is not limited to located in or
generated by his body so he knows that
although he seems to be a separate
individual what he essentially is is
shared by everyone and everything and
his thoughts and feelings and his
subsequent activities and relationships
are informed by this understanding now
David does not realize this Allen's
friend of David believes it he returns
friend David reasons with himself well
every time I close my eyes the world
disappears every time I open my eyes the
world of the streets of London in this
case they reappear so it's perfectly
obvious that whatever it is that
perceives the world must live just
behind my eyes in my brain and was
obviously generated by my brain it is
limited to my brain and my my brain dies
my consciousness will die with it in
other words David believes that he is a
temporary finite self that is separate
from albeit related to everyone and
everything else and all his thoughts and
feelings are almost all his thoughts and
feelings and his subsequent activities
and relationships are informed by that
understanding so Alan and David have
very different kinds of thoughts there
different instrument players in that
sense as well if one player is playing
oh they're different they're different
instruments but what's more important is
that the understanding that is expressed
through the instrumentality of each of
their bodies is a different
understanding although ultimately it is
all the activity of an Allen asleep in
South Dakota
nevertheless in one case that the in
case of Allen in the dream that his
thoughts and feelings express the
reality and in David's case that they
they do not express that they Express
separation and as a result of the belief
in separation David is able to not only
think and feel but act and relate in the
ways that are not consistent with truth
love and to extrapolate now for it from
David if you were to take David's point
of view in extreme cases one whose
thoughts and feelings and subsequent
activities and relationships are
informed by this sense of separation is
able to commit acts of gross unkindness
and injustice they are still the
activities of the same infinite yes mind
but filtered through the sense of
separation they are able to behave in a
way that is not consistent with reality
whereas yes Allen's in the dream does
everything he says he is an artist and
the purpose of his art is to express his
understanding and communicated and share
it just as is the case with Allen in
real life it's so this is playing so
beautifully so the the ultimate dreamer
of infinite consciousness dreams up the
dreams up the the illusory universe in
the sense that it's and it does it's not
there doesn't seem to be exact
what did what it is wike yeah hold that
thought just from me again Goins right I
don't like to interact but I want to I
wanted to say this the last time you yes
please the illusionary world cuz I think
this is this is very important something
that I misunderstood for years and I
think it's something that causes a lot
of people who would otherwise be
interested in these matters and trouble
and for good reason with this approach
in and that is because this the world is
referred to as being an illusion and for
many people the idea that something is
an illusion is tantamount to saying that
it is not real so I want to make a very
clear distinction between something that
is not real and something that is an
illusion yes
so that just let's just use an example a
square circle try to imagine now a
square circle or in the Zen tradition
the one hand clapping okay but let's
stick with try to imagine now as a
square circle we can't do it in other
words it's not even possible to imagine
the illusory image of a square circle a
square circle is not an illusion it is
utterly non-existent however when we are
watching a movie for instance and we see
a landscape in the in the movie the the
landscape is obviously an illusion but
it is not non-existence there is
something that is there there is a
reality to the illusory landscape and of
course when we go out to it we touch the
landscape we find relatively speaking
that its reality is the squeezed green
yes
all of this that the world as you
rightly say from this in this
perspective the world is an illusion not
in the sense that it is not real it is
absolutely real in the sense that it is
the world is an illusion in the sense
that it is not what it appears to be it
appears to be a multiplicity and
diversity yeah objects themselves only
from
Limited and localized perspective of a
separate self or a finite mind yes yes
this is gonna play beautifully so yeah
so that was very important you'll go
back to your thought about the is that
that was very important Rupert thank you
so the ultimate dreamer of the infinite
consciousness we have this dreams this
the this the illusory which is it's not
what it appears to be Symphony and then
here's here's what we're I'm really
interested in this symphony the symphony
has the the these these eight billion
seemingly again illusory in the sense it
artists that are individual that are
being filtered through the finite mind
and that but here's here's something
interesting
my understanding of of infinite
consciousness I think and I think it was
um Ananda Krishna Menon who said that if
you do have to think of it in a sense
you can think of it as behind behind
behind you the infinite consciousness
and that the the more that you go
through the process of self abidance so
you go through Atma vichara self inquiry
to gain the realization of infinite
consciousness and then you have the
process of self abidance so the idea is
that you have potentially varying
degrees of artistry in the sense that
there are people that have deep self
abidance in infinite consciousness so
when they're playing their violin
they're doing it in as in the acronym
sto service to other so they're playing
their violin with service to other
because they're there they've they've
realized that versus maybe a clarinet
player who in the case of david in your
dream remember so this is where we can
connect the two analogies david in the
case of the dream hasn't went through
the deeper self ink
and self abidance process and so he is
under more of the acronym of ste s
service to self so he is playing the
clarinet but that's why he's also going
through the process of seeking objects
relationships substances all these
external things to make himself happy
and peaceful so how is that where I
think I feel like we're getting closer
to an interesting synthesis between yeah
dream is it do you see the spectrum also
in terms of the eight billion and do you
see them evolving as well in the sense
that someone that is service to self
inevitably Rupert we had slavery and we
don't have slavery anymore in much of
much of the world and so there is an
sort of ethical or consciousness or
awareness it not in a sense that that
consciousness or the awareness is
evolving but our ethics and our morals
and our philosophies are evolving to be
more towards service to other and more
towards the unity towards that truth of
the infinite consciousness yeah yes and
an ethical code would be a code that
laid down a series of behaviors that are
expressive of truth or reality that come
that that show people how to behave in
line with or in a way that is consistent
with the fact that everyone shares their
being that all ethics can be boiled down
to that single fact ethical behavior is
behavior that is consistent with the
fact that we all share our being this is
why
st. Augustine when asked about these
matters ethics and laws he simply said
love and do whatever you want he meant
simply realized that you are one with
everything and everyone and as long as
your behavior is consistent with that
understanding you don't need any moral
code that everything you do will be
consistent with that understanding the
reason why we need and ten commandments
or a moral code is but is for those of
us that do not yet feel this we are we
are told how to behave in a way that is
consistent with this understand until we
realize it for our self so let's go back
to David and the symphony so the
violinist is you say in in your analogy
the violinist is what is one who is is
aware of that she shares her yes reality
yes with everyone and the clarinet is
does not yet realized this he still
believes and feels that he is a
temporary finite self however I would
suggest that many artists and many
musicians when they are in their studios
or when they are performing in their in
their quartets or their bands or their
orchestras that they are at least for
the duration for a period of time in
which they are performing they aren't
they their art they transcend yeah their
limitations as a person and they perform
in a way that is expressive of truth or
reality when they then go back to their
everyday lives they revert to believing
and feeling that they are a separate
self or an ego but many people in fact
this is why for some for many artists
there that their art is a kind of it's
it's it's not a compulsion it's
something that they they can't not do
that they know that when they are in
their studios or performing in their
orchestras or band they are in touch
with something that they know is so
utterly alive and true and in that
moment they do transcend the sense of
separation they are expressing that
truth reality love so it's not it's not
black and white it's not either you've
recognized yourself you know your true
nature and everything you do expresses
that or you haven't yet there is a
spectrum yes beautiful yes and he's not
only true sorry it's not only true of
artists it's true of everybody
yes exactly in that sense all a billion
are artists in that sense all a million
of us know the experience of love in
other words everybody has tasted the
fact that we share our being and
everybody has had the experience of
behaving and relating in a way that is
consistent with that understanding for
most people it's only that behavior is
only directed towards a few people in
their circle their friends or their
family yes
but nevertheless they've still
understood and felt what it is to share
our being even if that is not their
consistent experience in Ruppert would
you say that we are over the last
several thousand years if not tens of
thousands of years that we have been
going more and more towards the the
general general real the full embodied
realization more I hope so because
that's that's and that's the general
idea of what it like an evolution when
people say that word that yeah I tend to
be optimistic everything ultimately is
destined to return to its source there
is nowhere else for it to return to so
ultimately everything is there or in
souls one could argue that there is more
more violence more
Harmonie more conflict in the world
today I would suggest that that the old
structures were in in our society were
egoic structures they were structured in
our corporations in our governments in
our institutions in earth they were
structures that were based upon an egoic
sense of self as more than ironical a
separate self and that expresses itself
in extremes in indeed tyrannical
dictatorships but also in much smaller
ways in in families in companies in
communities and that they said the sense
of separation can express each other but
so I would suggest that let them the
chaos we see in in our society today and
that the violence the conflict I hope
and I believe that it is the evidence
that these structures are falling apart
because they're not based in truth or
reality and although we're witnessing a
time of great upheaval I hope that and I
believe that that it makes it makes it
for the possibility that a new order
will emerge one that is based on yes I
shared being it just must be that
there's a single understanding exact
like we share our being when everyone
and everything must be the foundation of
any truly civilized culture it must be
at the origin of a civilized culture I
love that I love that that first
principle of recognition of shared being
yeah it's the principle that it should
be the fundamental principle of all but
not only of all of us but but but
because we're speaking of the world of
all politicians
yes exactly all politics should learn
this service of one idea or one
understanding alone namely everyone and
everything when I say everything I
include everything because I'm not just
talking about animals and people I'm
talking about the earth
yes but everyone and everything share
their being but that that should be the
single guiding principle of all people
in general but politicians yes that
their policies their individual policies
then in relation to different different
situations and event would would be the
means by which this understanding was
then expressed and shared and
communicated and implicated in society
yes we have been very obsessed about
taking that recognition of shared being
and having a deeply embodied at Davos at
the World Economic Forum in the global
500 top companies all the presidents and
congresses of the world in Hollywood in
Silicon Valley all these places
especially in people that have so much
guiding influence are the most important
especially to have that recognition of
shared being be that forceful and and
when it becomes the first principle
Rupert it also enables the recognition
that my clarinet or violin or saxophone
or drums or bass or whatever I'm doing
it must be for the the the service to
other it must be for augmenting the
social fabric for enabling the basic
needs on like a Maslow's hierarchy to be
met so that if air water food energy
education health care etc are met it
enables people to have a deeper self
abidance it enables the inquiry into the
true nature of reality plus it enables
them to become an art artists in
symphony as well and so that's sort of
the general process that at least I see
one who is one who not only understands
but feel that they share their being
with everyone and everything they play
in tune
that's in the symphony and one who does
not feel this plays out of tune out of
tune china
hoard materialistic possessions and that
type of stuff that that versus playing
in tune I like that I like that as well
that's so so excellent Wow yeah time
time has flown do do you believe in our
ability to leverage science in the sense
that there's all of these new
technological methodologies that exist
including fMRI EEG EKG the samples of
the microbiome do you believe in our
ability to have a biometric correlate to
a non dual state of awareness
what would a biometric corrala look like
yeah yeah so it would be something like
a like for example with brain it would
be like a connectome harmonic and so
that would be like the total of all of
your chemo electro connectomics are in a
harmonic state of resonance maybe with
your heart it would be that you have a
higher heart rate variability versus a
lower heart rate variability for
something that's more stressed in that
sense so there are these biomarkers for
cortisol are there these biomarkers for
for for more blissful or meditative or
peaceful states of consciousness states
of awareness so do you see science
potentially helping with a with a
biometric correlate of a more awakened
aware enlighten states of being science
may discover
correlates that indicate the ones state
of mind but whether they will help
whether those discoveries will actually
help in the recognition we're speaking
of I I'm I'm not so sure it's if you
were so optimistic or no no I am very
optimistic I just I just don't feel that
that these correlates that scientists
may or may not find in the brain aren't
helpful either as indicators or more
importantly as means to the recognition
of our true nature if we look if we want
some measure of the indication of some
measure of our establishment in our true
nature I'm not sure that looking at a
brain scan is the place to look we
should look to the extent to which we
are at peace and happy for no reason
that would be a better test
imperturbable peace yes and causeless
joy ooh imperturbable peace and
causeless joy adore that ya know this to
recognize the nature of our selfie is is
so simple Alan it's been mystified yeah
and complexified and and obscured not by
the founders of the great religious and
spiritual traditions but by their
followers who did not understand or only
partially understood their teaching or
all that is necessary to go back to them
beginning about conversation is is this
metaphorical undressing this this
removing it's not even there so to
remove thoughts feelings activities
relationships all it's in other words
it's not necessary to change our
experience or manipulated in any way all
that is necessary is to see that element
of ourselves which cannot be taken away
from us to see that which is essential
to us not our thoughts not our feelings
sensations perceptions activities
relationships all of these appear and
disappear on the screen of awareness but
the awareness is that the essential and
irreducible nature of ourselves and if
this is something that is simple
everyone can recognize it simply by
virtue of the fact that everyone is
aware and everyone can simply it's not
as I said it's not necessary to reject
the content of experience all that is
necessary is to relax the focus of our
attention from its content
yeah and just just relax bank into the
fact of being aware which is the the
ever-present an inherently peaceful
background of all experience that's all
and to begin with that this background
of awareness it seems to be a place that
we visit from time to time and then we
get lost in the content of experience
again but in time it ceases that the
back and forth between the background of
awareness and the foreground of
experience ceases and we begin to be
what Krishna men are called we begin to
be established in our true nature we
cease just a visit from time to time the
piece of the background we we live there
we abide that we still face experience
we still have to deal with our our
everyday experience but everything we
think and feel and in time our
subsequent activities and relationships
are informed by and are an expression of
this background of of peace and
unconditional yes I love that always a
work in progress in the sense of always
becoming more and more established and I
think that's that's that's very
important in in making it easier for
peace
to feel like it's not a far-off thing
yeah yeah not only is it not a far-off
thing our being is is closer to us than
our most intimate and precious feelings
it is not even close to us it it is us
yeah yeah
and getting our entire world on that
closer closer closer and hopefully we
have been over time getting time getting
closer and closer to that and then and
then being your unique artistry from
that is I think the the general essence
of where we are got in in much of this
yes all of us interested in these
matters you and I and all your viewers
and express our understanding such as it
is in a way that is unique to us you
know I do it through speaking and
writing I used to do it in my my studio
but there there are so many ways so many
ways some of them require a lot of form
a lot of content they involve speaking
or writing or or your lovely drawings of
you behind other people may not express
this understanding in form that they may
just abide rest yeah being and that they
they're the ones that that communicate
that this understandings silently yes
I'm sure that we all know yes what it's
like to to be in the company of someone
who is at ease who is at peace yes
anything irrespective of how wealthy or
impoverished they may be haha
often it is to be in the company of such
a person and how when we go home we feel
somehow blessed just by being with them
we may have chatted about the weather or
politics or dinner or we may not have
spoken directly about these matters as
you and I have done that and they may
such people may never speak directly
about these matters but they communicate
this understanding silently and and and
that their communication their
contribution to humanity is just as
valuable as those of us that yes Express
this understanding in more formalized
ways let's thank you and as we say in in
music what makes music music is the
silence between the notes yes yeah yeah
yeah Rupert one more question is is that
okay man okay we're talking about this
this soap this trajectory of hopefully
becoming more and more self abiding in
that and channeling that as artistry
through us where what is the what is the
Telos what is the purpose for the
ultimate dreamer infinite consciousness
to make the dream what is the purpose of
it and in terms of trajectory to heading
towards some sort of a Godhead what what
happens
do we Ouroboros another dream is that
yeah and and and what's the relationship
with artificial intelligence and like
virtual realities and simulation theory
with that Godhead and that continued or
Boris please my mother who first
introduced me to these matters in my in
my mid-teens
reminds me quite often that when I was
about seven years old I
said to her I think that the entire
universe is God's dream and that our
part in the dream is to make God's dream
as nice a dream as possible well that
was an innocent naive seven-year-olds
way of expressing what we are speaking
of now and I have to confess that I have
not evolved very much over the
intervening 50 or so years I still
basically feel the same thing although I
express it in somewhat more
sophisticated language but so I still
think that the universe is God's dream I
don't often use that language although I
am really a closet Sufi I tend not to
use that language because the word God
has is so intolerable to so many people
thought for for obvious reasons it has
been abused so much so I tend not to use
that language I consider this to be the
activity of an infinite consciousness as
to the purpose of it to answer your
question I would no longer say that I
think its purpose is to be as nice as
possible a dream for God to have so that
God doesn't have to have nightmares or
is its ultimate purpose I would suggest
is that it be is for the reality to
shine unobscured through the illusion so
the the illusion being the appearance of
multiplicity and diversity which for
most of us conceals its reality I would
suggest that the purpose if we can speak
of purpose is for the the illusion the
appearance of multiplicity and diversity
not to conceal its reality but to reveal
its reality to express it to communicate
it to share it to celebrate it in other
words for for the appearance to become
increasingly transparent to its reality
and I believe beautiful and I believe of
Francis Lucille says it's a eternal 4th
of July fireworks he said that I think
yes yes and I I like I like that as as
the purpose for the reality to shine
through the illusion yeah I like I like
that and and it does seem like it's
there's like a there's a titration in a
sense if we can use that more and more
towards that towards that remembrance
and and it and that's Rupert there's a
lot about artificial intelligence and
virtual realities and simulations that I
think have a lot to do with the Godhead
that's for another conversation let's
not get started on that now ok all right
all right Rupert Wow this has been such
a pleasure thank you thank you for
joining us well this Thank You Alan for
inviting me it's been a pleasure
speaking with you I have managed during
our conversation not to get distracted
by the fascinating drawings on the wall
behind you fortunately they're just out
of focus I can't read them but they look
they look marvelous and it's a pleasure
to to to meet you in this way and to
have them had this conversation and I
hope our paths will cross again I either
virtually if not in person person yeah
likewise likewise Rupert hopefully um
all of all of this is the your
contributions are present in all of this
all of these brilliant artists that I'm
kind of sponging up and then and then
I'm I'm wringing out the sponge into
this art to share well I think talking
about different characters Allen playing
different instruments expressing the
same understanding your background and
my background in this conversation
they express our two different
characters very nice both singing the
same song but in in very different ways
yeah yeah and and rupert if you guys saw
all of the links are in the bio too
Rupert's work check out Rupert's YouTube
channel it's just exploding he has a
bunch of really great videos on it
unpacking the essence of non-duality so
please do check that out also
Rupert Spiricom the links in the bio
below has all of his United States and
Europe retreats that he hosts yes
although sorry to interrupt yes everyone
on hold on Monday I hope it's coming
again it's coming and I hope I know you
do retreats in the Northern California
region where we host our studio show and
so hopefully to meet in person then and
and also our show given the studio's
interest in Los Angeles as well it's
very interesting to potentially have you
host you down there
for a retreat in that area and help
catalyze more people to attend so
because that's another market we were
talking about Silicon Valley and
Hollywood California is the fifth
largest economy in in the world and so
to have as a state by itself so to have
you also bring your skills your your
stories your sharing to Los Angeles to
Hollywood would also be very important
Rupert Wow so grateful so grateful thank
you thank you for inviting me take a
deep well and until we meet again yes
and so we meet again thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode we
would love to hear from you get chatting
in the comments about all the different
things that Rupert was sharing about
what we were going back and forth on we
would love to hear your thoughts again
check out all the links in the bye
Rupert's work do check all that out go
follow him across platforms share his
work if it resonates
attendez retreats and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leader support the people in your
communities around the world that are
making impact that you believe in
support them help them flourish and also
unleash your own gifts as well and build
that more beautiful future our hearts
know as possible we love you very much
thank you for tuning in we will see you
soon bye everyone
peace namaste
[Music]
you
[Music]
I think I did you actually provided me
with a very interesting synthesis of the
dream with the symphony in a sense it's
nice I like the way that we went back
and forth between the two and because
each one has a certain each one is good
for illustrating a slightly different
aspect of the understanding and I
thought it was nice it was like weaving
a blanket out of threads it worked very
nicely
yeah I loved it and now we get to lay in
it and yeah
[Laughter]
you